hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to be talking about
aikido wrist techniques and what the
heck's going on with those
all right guys so today we're going to
be talking about the aikido wrist
techniques
aikido risk techniques the the
techniques for wrists in aikido
are one of probably the most stand out
things people notice about aikido so
early on people like
whoa that's the the martial art that has
a lot of those kind of wrist techniques
and that's really cool
important thing to understand is aikido
certainly did not invent wrist
techniques risk techniques have been
around for a really long time so
lots of different martial arts have risk
techniques um in japan when we're
talking about martial arts to have a lot
of risk techniques we're talking about
koryu jiu-jitsu and kodu jujitsu just
means old-school jiu-jitsu old-style
jiu-jitsu now old-style
jitsu was focused on battlefield
grappling it wasn't focused on
unarmed situations right in japan when
you were doing unarmed situations that
was sumo right
when you were talking about battlefield
grappling you were talking about
jiu-jitsu
so aikido has a relationship to
old-style jiu-jitsu and that's why we
have those techniques in our system
and for the context in which we're
talking about aikido it's really hard to
pull those techniques out so we need
those techniques
now in the modern era where we're really
focused on unarmed martial arts
risk techniques are a low percentage
thing so if you're in an unarmed
situation you're unarmed and they're
unarmed doing a wrist technique is low
percentage not
impossible you can see some examples of
it being done
but but very low percentage now in ikito
inside the context that we're working on
they actually become
high percentage techniques now the
context is what you have to understand
and what that context is
so today we're going to be talking about
that with josh and maya i'm going to
show you a progression of drills that we
use at this school
that aren't aikido but they're kind of
aikido adjacent and they will improve
your aikido risk techniques
if you work on these drills so i'm going
to get josh and maya here josh maya
let's go to work
all right so we're going to take you
guys through a series of drills that i
use here at the dojo
building from really simple to a hard
practice right a more complicated
practice
and in these we're going to work on
wrist techniques now
why do we need wrist techniques in the
first place we need them to take
something out of someone's hand or also
could be
to clear someone who's grabbing our hand
right
now why would there be such hand
emphasis well because there's some kind
of weapon so we're going to use this
short stick right now
for our weapon all it is is 18 inch
rattan dowel sets it real simple thing
you could use it you cut a broom handle
you cut an old joe that's broken
whatever you want this is the size stick
we're going to use
so this is going to be our our weapon
right now no
it just is what it is it's a stick so
don't pretend like it's a super deadly
knife or anything else right it's it's
just a stick it's that simple
and the idea of this progression is to
teach
general skills right so we're getting
general skills so even you've been doing
aikido a long time if you haven't done
this drill
work on this in a very very basic way
okay so the first thing we're going to
do here
is we'll have maya working against josh
here so josh is going to hold the stick
in the middle like this
okay maya's going to grab either side of
the stick like this
now right now all maya's going to do is
take the stick out of josh's hand josh
is going to provide
no resistance right so zero resistance
so she's gonna turn that dowel somehow
and she's gonna find a way that it comes
out of his hand now she's not going to
use any kind of crazy explosive action
or anything
right none of that because josh is
holding it really light so there's no
need for that so all this is is a
technical understanding or a
clarification of technical understanding
of what's happening when she lightly
tries to remove the stick from josh's
hand
now when she's doing this she's trying
to find good simple easy little angles
that make it easy for the stick to come
out of the hand and that's it that's all
she's looking for and josh isn't
resisting her at all and she's going
through that
okay generally what we'll do is three on
one hand three on the other hand
and then we'll switch over and josh will
get to do the drill for her so that's
phase one right that's the number one
face okay now the next one
josh is going to stay in the basic same
position but all he's going to do is
hold it as hard as he can
so with his hand he's going to hold it
as hard as he possibly can
maya's going to work to remove it okay
now again
maya wants to if she possibly can um she
wants you to keep going
she wants to just take it out normally
she doesn't want to use any explosive
action
now it's a little bit harder for her not
a whole lot harder because honestly josh
is pretty rigid right now so
it's still not super hard but what she's
doing is she's starting to get the
general idea of what it's like to remove
something
with resistance right so he's really
trying to hold it hard and she's trying
to remove it from his hand so
this is the next phase up again maya's
gonna really refrain from using any
explosive actions that she can
although she might need to right so josh
could be so strong that she will need to
use a little oomph
to get it out of there but if she can
that's that she wants to avoid that kind
of stuff
okay so that's phase two all right and
again we do it
uh three right hand three left hand then
switch over okay
phase three so in phase three what's
gonna happen here
is maya is going to try to remove it but
josh is gonna use
more dynamic resistance right now what i
mean by dynamic resistance is
and just kind of fake it real slow here
so they can see us as maya starts to
move it
josh is going to move his arm around and
configure himself in different positions
to make it more difficult for her to
take it out of his hand now this is not
hugely
more difficult because josh still isn't
moving his feet or anything but as
john go ahead and move at real speed now
so but as maya's trying to get this out
of his hand
josh is going to move his body around
until she can find a way to get it out
now it's important to understand that
the way she's taking it out of his hand
his hand is still exactly the same way
she was using before it's just now josh
is dynamically opposing her so he's
moving his arm in different ways to
trying to
oppose her actions okay good so that's
phase three
and this is a dynamic phase now phase
four in this oh and in that by the way
maya might use some explosive actions
because she needs to but again she's
always trying to keep herself
using as few dynamic actions as possible
and the reason is because she wants to
get as good at the technique as possible
and not just good at going faster or
harder okay now sorry phase four
phase four so in phase four what we're
going to do here is josh is allowed to
turn his hand over so
let's say maya and go real easy right
now my gets it to a point where it's
about to come out of the hand
josh can turn his hand over and re-grip
right and he can re-grip any way he
wants right so as she turns it over bang
he's going to try and re-grip
in a good way so as maya's trying to
twist it out now you guys can go life's
full speed
okay so an esme is trying to twist it
out josh is going to be able to re-grip
and grab it now is
if his hand comes off that's fine josh
is still working
what maya wants to do is now learn to to
separate it out just like that so she
wants to pull it away
so as she's working to get it out and
josh is switching his grip over she's
trying to find a way
to do it now she's not going to block
his hands like she just did they're
starting to amp up over here because i'm
talking too much
and they're getting antsy but um so
basically she's gonna try and just stick
to the stick right now and working the
stick out and josh is flipping his grip
over as much as he can
and my is trying to flip it over and
pull it away from him okay so that's our
phase four
now our phase five josh can
intermittently switch his hand so and go
ahead and do a slow one for us here so
as they start to turn it over
he can turn and don't turn your back to
the camera just stay say where you guys
can all see
so as she starts to break it out of his
hand josh can switch that other hand
over
now in phase five he's not allowed to
have two hands on only one hand on at a
time right
so he's always got a switch so what josh
or maya's looking for is a little break
and as he goes to switch
she can pull it away right so that way
he can't get to it right so this is our
phase five
go ahead and move a little bit full full
action so they can see so she's trying
to get it out josh trying to switch his
hand over
right and every time and josh is not
also just gonna wait there by it right
so he's not gonna do this number right
because
he's also training himself to be able to
make switches from different odd spots
right so
okay good excellent job all right so
that's our phase five now in our phase
six they're going to start in the same
position
but the second that maya moves so the
second shift to move
josh can add his second hand in okay so
the second mine starts to move josh can
add that second hand okay now they're
wrestling two on two on two
so that's a fair a fair exchange now
we're giving maya the beginning
advantage so
that is a good opportunity for her to
try and explode as fast as she can
initially and what's good is this is
kind of training josh also
because josh is learning to deal with
something that happens really suddenly
in real explosion so
it's on maya's go when maya wants to go
then josh immediately adds a second hand
okay now i'm gonna get out of here in
just a second and they can actually go
for it and they're getting antsy so they
really want to
to go but what we're gonna do here is
we're gonna run it and once we're in
phase six
they can move around as much as they
want so now you guys are gonna get to
see them go and we're gonna go just for
a minute here
and let them run with it and then you
guys can kind of see how the full phase
of the practice works
now it's important don't just jump to
phase six go through the progression as
i was outlining
but i'm going to get out of here and let
these guys go to work
[Music]
so
good time all right guys so that's the
six stage progression
i use to start getting the students used
to what risk techniques are how to do
them how to resist against them
how to move and change and adapt with
them so that's a really basic practice
that practice can go into a much more
live practice later
so that is totally live practice in and
of itself they're both trying as hard as
they can to get the stick out of each
other's hands
and you can see in phase six once both
hands are on
either person could tear it out so you
had josh tearing it out sometimes am i
tearing it out the other time so whoever
gets it gets the stick
and the whole objective of that practice
is just to get the stick so
you could try throws and stuff too and
you notice they didn't it's not because
throws were off the table
it's because a lot of times throws don't
actually help and if you start focusing
more on doing a throw
than you do on getting the weapon out a
lot of times you'll throw them with the
weapon in their hand
and then that doesn't help you right and
there might be times that that does help
you but
the goal of that practice is to get good
at
taking something out of someone's hand
which is what a wrist technique actually
is
so i could take any brand new person off
the street and i've done this
in our self-defense seminars i take a
brand new person off the street and i
just
teach them the drill i don't teach them
how you're going to take anything out of
anyone's hand or anything else
and by the end of that drill the
students who never saw wrist technique
before
will instantly be doing coda geishas and
nico's like crazy they'll be doing tons
of them
and the reason is because those
techniques are super high percentage
for that context and the context is
taking something out of someone's hand
so you will see tons of nikki's encoded
issues from people who have never been
taught the technique before
you'd be shocked at how quickly people
can learn this stuff when you just give
them a live drill like this to work with
so this live drill starts teaching you
how to work with wrist techniques
now one more caveat i have to add
actually probably two more caveats
one for safety and one for practicality
this is not the system of aikido so what
you just saw is not the system of aikido
it is not the ideal way to use a
systematic approach to deal with
conflict
this is a struggle right so this is a
struggling method so not the system of
aikido now it uses some of the
techniques we see in aikido
and it's a good way to improve and get
better at those techniques but this is
systematically not what you would want
to do in aikido right and aikido i
wouldn't want to
rest assured on my skill of holding
something in my hand and present
something for someone to take it out of
my hand
and then we wrestle over and because i'm
better then i could go haha i beat you
because i've got superior skills at that
um that's not the goal right i could
have a whole systematic approach
however for the tiny bit of kumiuchi
struggle methods that involve wrist
techniques
this is a great drill to start out with
and kind of progress through
don't skip ahead right so go through
each individual
stage even if it seems boring each stage
will teach you more and more and as you
start getting more and more to the
advanced stages in level six
you'll start appreciating level one more
because i personally work with level one
a lot because
i'm trying to figure out the most
efficient angles to turn something to
get it out of someone's hand so it can
give you a lot of skills there
now the final safety warning i want to
give you with this when you guys are
really wrestling over it hard that stick
can have a tendency to fly at your face
and
i have had students leave with big
bruises on their heads and and teeth can
become endangered so
be careful and aware of that um wearing
face shield would be a great idea
or putting in a mouth guard or
something's a good idea um and at the
very least be very careful of each
other's faces when you start doing that
don't get so rambunctious that you
break each other's teeth out alright so
i'm done giving my safety speech
i'm christopher hine thanks a lot for
[Music]
watching